bonjour christian ouanna merci de
répondre à nos questions à ce matin sur
arte france et d'accompagner la cie à
6,93 exactement est au coeur de
nombreuses polémiques un déjà
puisqu'elle avait été donc on l'a dit
dissoute en en juillet on a l'impression
que les hommes passent mais que les
dérives perdure comment l'expliquez
comment y remédier et surtout alors bay
ce qu'on sait c'est que il ya un mandat
qui est donné un certain nombre de
policiers dans les quartiers pour
maintenir une certaine pression sur les
populations et la difficulté est
justement de trouver le bon niveau entre
des interventions qui peuvent être
justifiées violente et parfois un
certain nombre de dérives qu'on constate
des condamnations sont elles possibles
quelles suites pénales selon vous les
conduisent les condamnations sont
possibles d'un point de vue juridique la
vraie question elle est est ce qu'il y
aura une enquête dont on a vu que dans
le cas dans ce cas-là l'igpn a fait une
enquête qui a un travail qui a été fait
par l'igpn a presque y aura des suites
judiciaires
il faut voir si la justice ira jusqu'au
bout parce qu'elle a toujours elle
craint un petit peu de se mettre à dos
les policiers qui très souvent quand il
ya un procès comme ça au tribunal font
une démonstration un peu de force pour
impressionner les magistrats la police
n'est pas raciste la police n'est pas
violente c'est ce qu'avait dit on s'en
souvient laurent denis est l'ex
secrétaire d'état à l'intérieur
désormais c'est gérald darmanin qui est
à beauvau comment est-ce qu'il peut
réconcilier les citoyens et la police
même si selon les derniers sondages les
français aiment la police a priori alors
les français aiment la police depuis
assez longtemps
d'une manière globale ce qu'on sait
c'est que cette confiance de la
population dans la police elle a
tendance à baisser très fortement depuis
une dizaine d'années et de manière
encore plus accentuée ces dernières
années et par ailleurs on sait qu'il ya
un certain nombre de populations celle
qui a le plus affaire à la police parce
qu'elle est plus contrôlée pas seulement
les délinquants mais parce qu'il ya des
gens qui sont plus contrôlés qu'ils sont
plus soumis à cette pression policière
et on sait que c'est chez ces gens là il
ya une détestation de la police il ya
des tensions très vives
pour en revenir au ministre de
l'intérieur il ya depuis très longtemps
des travaux qui disent que il faut
réconcilier la police et la population
notamment dans les quartiers sensibles
notamment avec les jeunes
notamment avec les manifestants type
gilet jaune et ce qu'on voit c'est
plutôt une stratégie contraire de la
part de l'état qui a tendance à être de
plus en plus rigides dans le maintien de
l'ordre on l'a vu avec votre sujet
précédent
et puis quand on voit revenir la culture
du chiffre et quand on sait ce que ça
signifie en terme de pression surtout
qu'on voit bien qu'il ya des exigences
de résultats chiffrés il faut des
interros de but au début du moins en
demande aux policiers de produire des
interpellations de produire des pv on
sait très bien que ça amène plein
d'effets pervers et que ça va plutôt
irrité les policiers que ça va être une
pression sur eux pression qui va se
repère répercuter sur leurs relations
avec la population
selon vous qu'est ce qui peut se passer
lors de ces prochaines semaines par
rapport à cette thématique
on a souvent des nouvelles affaires qui
reviennent au niveau de l'actualité
est-ce qu'il va y en avoir de nouvelles
est ce qu'il va y avoir des décisions
qui vont être prises comme le
gouvernement devrait selon vous gérer ce
phénomène de nouvelles parce que quand
on voit de plus en plus d'affaires où il
ya des policiers eux mêmes qui dénoncent
le comportement de certains de leurs
collègues parce que évidemment tous les
policiers ne sont pas racistes bien
entendu tous les pôles les policiers ne
sont pas violents mais il est
extrêmement difficile à l'intérieur de
la police de de dénoncer ces pratiques
aussi parce que il ya un espèce
d'encouragement du gouvernement qui
incite les policiers à être dans ce
qu'on appelle le saute dessus
l'intervention est pas du tout dans une
logique de ce qu'on a pu appeler à une
époque une police de proximité ou ce
qu'on appelle ailleurs une police plus
proche de la population c'est-à-dire des
policiers qui ne sont pas là uniquement
pour faire du recul du résultat mais qui
sont aussi là pour participer pour
rassurer les populations pour discuter
avec elle et ça demande un ancrage local
très fort ce qui n'est pas dans les
stratégies actuelles
est-ce que ça pour elle réellement
fonctionné cette police
de proximité que vous appelez ce qu'on a
suffisamment de 2
d'effectifs pour cela notamment sa pose
la question d'où sont les effectifs
policiers on parle depuis des années
deux entre guillemets re mettre du bleu
dans la rue remettre des policiers dans
la rue il y en a beaucoup qui sont dans
des bureaux qui sont à faire des
rapports qui sont dans des tâches
justement quand il ya une manifestation
comme on voit par exemple le tour de
france ou d'autres types de
manifestations ça mobilise beaucoup de
policiers qui ne seront pas disponibles
pour autre chose quand il ya une visite
officielle sa me mobilise maintenant
5000 6000 policiers pour une visite
officielle de quelques heures est ce
qu'il faudrait justement pas prendre
plus d'effectifs pour être dans cette
mission de rapprochement avec la
population on l'a vu dans plein d'autres
pays européens il ya des stratégies de
rapprochement avec la population qui
marche qui fonctionne qui font que
l'image de la police s'améliore y
compris auprès des gens qui
habituellement sont plutôt mal vue par
la police donc on sait qu'il ya des
stratégies qui marche on a pu les valu
le faire en france est évalué à une
certaine époque là ce qui est un peu
décevant c'est qu'on voit pas trop de
d'innovation de la part du ministère de
l'intérieur actuellement merci christian
mouhanna d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes chargé de
recherche au cnrs et membre du centre de
recherches sociologiques sur le droit et
les institutions pénales